[Musique]
comme vous pouvez le constater nous
avons bien reçu tous vos calculs
monsieur d'una mais nous avons
l'impression que vous mener une double
vie
dans l'une de ces villes vous êtes
matador vous passionné par les sciences
et les mathématiques en particulier vous
avez une licence de mathématiques vous
avez enseigné un peu et vous avez une
chaîne youtube qui s'appelle matador
mais vous avez une autre vie à côté
où vous êtes le musicien connu sous le
nom de 507 heures une autre chaîne
youtube où vous racontez votre quotidien
d'intermittents du spectacle mais une
seule de ces vies a un avenir
l'autre n'en a aucun
qu'il me soit permis de vous expliquer
ce qui nous amène monsieur franck
nous comptons sur vous pour nous faire
quelques calculs nous avions tout à fait
confiance dans votre capacité de travail
mais il semble que cela prenne beaucoup
trop de temps mes collègues pensent que
c'est parce que vous préférez faire de
la musique
mais moi je pense que vous saurez faire
le bon choix
nous sommes même disposé à mettre de
côté votre vie de troubadour nous vous
demandons seulement en échange de votre
coopération dans le but de finir ses
calculs au plus vite
ouais
1 j'utilise les matrices c'est quoi ça
ce que je suive le lapin blanc
toc toc qui est là c'est moi
ouais qu'est ce que vous voulez on sera
en ville tu viens au thales allait bien
sûr un peu je te feras un verre chez
ok d'accord bonsoir franck qu'est ce que
vous voulez je viens t d en maths mais
de akwa servir des matrices c'était toi
sur mon ordinateur et comment t'as fait
ça pour l'instant tout ce que je peux te
dire c'est que tu te galère pour rien je
sais pourquoi tu n'avances pas je sais
tout ce qu'il te reste à faire
je sais pourquoi tu les antennes entre
tous ces x et y
et pourquoi lui après lui tu restes
devant ses calculs
moi aussi j'ai beaucoup galéré devant
ces équations coup mais je n'ai plus ce
problème depuis que j'ai la réponse
à quoi ça sert les matrices la réponse
est là elle t'attend rejoint mois chez
morpheus
expliquera tout et tu verras leur
puissance
[Musique]
voilà notre matheux assieds-toi neo
finira dessus ces exercices franck non
et pourquoi parce qu'il ya trop de
calculs à faire et je m'embrouille bien
sûr et c'est pour ça que je vais t'aider
je vais te dire pourquoi tu es là tu es
là pour apprendre quelque chose
les matrices tu vas devoir te concentrer
tuera peut-être mal au crâne
alors prends un doliprane
si tu en as besoin ensuite prendre cette
pilule rouge et je te ferai un petit
cours sur les matrices
[Applaudissements]
ceci est notre cerveau
nous sommes dans le monde des maths
on pia
ce qu'on veut des nombres des variables
des équations
des espaces sectorielle
et en ce qui
le cern
des matrices
tu vas apprendre les matrices sur cette
vieille télé as tu vraiment besoin d'un
écran 85 pouces assis toi on va
commencer et on a pas mieux que ce
fauteuil pourri non il n'y a pas mieux
et je te rappelle qu'on est là pour les
maths ça ce sont les maths que tu
pratiques
des maths avec des équations dans tous
les sens
des calculs parfois trop lourd et trop
complexe à manipuler sur lesquels tu
échoues voici les mêmes calculs
avec les matrices
[Musique]
une matrice et un tableau qui peut
contenir des nombres et lettres ou
d'autres choses mais aujourd'hui nous
allons nous limiter aux nombres ses
tableaux sont des outils qui permettent
de faciliter et alléger un travail
mathématiques beaucoup plus conséquent
prenons un exemple concret il peut
arriver que nous soyons en présence
d'une collection de nombre et que nous
devions effectuer le même calcul pour
chacun de ces nombres imaginons quatre
employés qui ont travaillé chacun des
durées différentes mais sont tous
rémunérés à hauteur de 12 euros de
l'heure
le premier employé paul à travailler
trois heures le second john à travailler
5 heures georges
le troisième a travaillé sept heures le
quatrième richard a travaillé 9 heures
comment savoir combien on doit verser à
chaque salarié
a priori c'est simple il y a quatre
multiplication à faire mais nous avons
là une liste de quatre calcul quasiment
identiques et il peut être plus pratique
de tout résumé dans un tableau de cette
façon un premier tableau qui résume les
nombres d'heures ce tableau qui est
multiplié par le taux horaire commun à
savoir ici 12 et enfin le résultat qui
est lui aussi donné sous forme d'un
tableau et qui contient les quatre
multiplication tu l'aura donc compris
ces deux tableaux c'est ça qu'on appelle
des matrices dans notre cas les matrices
que l'on utilise ne contiennent que
quatre lignes et une seule colonne c'est
vraiment le cas le plus simple que l'on
peut rencontrer et manipuler c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que tu ne vois pas
forcément la puissance de cet outil il
faut que tu saches que l'on peut
augmenter la taille des matrices à
volonté en ajoutant des lignes et des
colonnes à quoi peut bien servir ces
colonnes supplémentaire me diras tu es
bien là encore laisse moi te donner un
exemple imaginons que nos quatre garçons
n'est plus le même salaire horaire par
les djeunes touche 20 euros de l'heure
alors que george touche 15 euros de
l'heure et richard seulement 12 euros de
l'heure
imaginons qu'il travaille dans une
société de fabrication de disques et
qu'ils soient débordés par la demande
ils doivent alors faire des heures
supplémentaires et là encore le taux
horaire diffèrent selon les gars sont
dans ce cas
paul et john touche 30 euros de l'heure
alors que george touche 20 euros de
l'heure et richard seulement 15 euros de
l'heure dans la semaine qui vient de
s'écouler
les quatre garçons ont travaillé dans
des durées différentes 35 heures pour
paul et john 20 heures georges et 28
heures pour richard côté heures
supplémentaires 20h pour paul 10h pour
john 0 pour georges et trois heures pour
richard
comment résumer tout cela évidemment il
y a la solution qui vient à l'esprit
naturellement et qui donnerait quelque
chose comme ça des tableaux qui résume
l'ensemble des données que je viens de
dénoncer mais comment manipuler ses
tableaux pour faire des calculs et bien
figure toi que ces deux tableaux peuvent
être facilement résumer dans deux
matrices distincte de cette façon dans
cette colonne le salaire de base dans
cette colonne le salaire des heures
supplémentaires sur cette ligne le
nombre d'heures fait à partir du salaire
de base est sur cette ligne
le nombre d'heures fait à partir des
heures supplémentaires et voilà la
puissance des matrices car ces deux
matrices sont deux objets mathématiques
et même si elle transporte beaucoup de
nombre il est possible de les combiner
par les opérations courantes comme
l'addition la soustraction etc
par exemple si l'on multiplie ses deux
matrices ensemble on obtient le résultat
suivant le résultat de la première ligne
de la première colonne c'est-à-dire 1300
c'est le salaire de paul sur une semaine
le résultat de la deuxième ligne de la
deuxième colonne c'est le salaire de
john de la même façon sur toutes les
diagonales on peut voir sous nos yeux
que le produit de ces deux matrices
donne le salaire des quatre garçons
puissant non mais attends tu n'as encore
rien vu car si tu regardes le résultat
de la première ligne quatrième colonne
ce 650 t'indique en un clin d'oeil ce qu
aurait gagné richard s'ils étaient payés
au tarif de paul
mais comment on les obtient tout ces
nombres la règle est simple lorsque deux
matrices sont multipliés entre elles tu
dois te concentrer sur le numéro de la
ligne qui est multiplié par le numéro de
la colonne prenons le cas de ceux 925
qui est le nombre qui figure sur la
troisième ligne est la première colonne
pour déterminer ce 925
il faut prendre la troisième ligne de la
première matrice et la multiplier avec
la première colonne de la deuxième
matrix le calcul à terre et donc 15 x 35
+ 20 x 20 ce qui donne 925
je commence à avoir mal à la tête là je
ne t'ai pas dit que ce serait facile
franck je t'ai dit que ça serait la
vérité mais rassure-toi la
multiplication et la plus difficile des
opérations car pour faire la somme des
deux matrices a rien de plus simple il
suffit d'ajouter les éléments un par un
par exemple si je dois faire la somme de
ces deux matrices il me suffit de
prendre chacun des éléments et de les
additionner l'utilisation des matrices
et ce en ligne à l'heure du big data et
de la manipulation de millions de nombre
en simultané à l'heure de l'intelligence
artificielle
à l'heure des calculs monstrueux en
temps réel que demandent les jeux vidéo
le calcul matricielle et incontournable
dans notre monde réel
maintenant que les bases ont été posées
la pilule rouge va poursuivre son effet
et tu va peu à peu
assimiler tous les rouages du monde des
matrices
[Musique]
je maîtrise les matrices prouve le mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]